Megan had stayed back in Cape Town we
now know she wanted to make one very
important visit the photo on their
Instagram account showing her paying her
respects where student was murdered last
month the Duchess joined hundreds of
others leaving a ribbon behind to show
solidarity 19 year old you Nene and wet
Jana was raped and murdered after going
to collect a parcel her body was then
dumped at the kaliesha Township on the
outskirts of Cape Town
Megan spoke with her mother earlier this
week to relay their condolences her
death has led to protests across South
Africa and this month the president
described the country as one most unsafe
places in the world to be a woman
gentler Ali was one of those who
organized the demos and welcomes Megan's
supports it's good for someone from of
that magnitude or people that are
high-profile to also help us in fighting
this issue I think it can't be an issue
that one part of society fights but it's
something that you only to come together
the need to call out the rising levels
of attacks on women and girls so
important to them they addressed it on
day one of their tour they told me it's
an issue they've been following closely
really peaked in the last in the last
month or so we've done our best to try
and keep track of what's been going on
Prince Harry was in Angola for his next
stop meeting the president the palace
always conscious the important
diplomatic work on behalf the government
doesn't get overlooked
as we've been flying around with Prince
Harry the palace have been conscious of
making sure that what the Duchess is
doing back in Cape Town hasn't been too
much of a distraction but when it comes
to that issue of gender-based violence
it is something that matters to them
both and as Megan wrote on the ribbon in
the local language we stand together in
this moment Rhiannon Mills Sky News in
Angola